what is the difference between faith in
jesus or having the faith of jesus
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome back to led live everybody we
are continuing this awesome series with
london lee here if you haven't checked
out any of his other videos man he just
did a powerful testimony in the
beginning of this series and we've been
talking about the faith of jesus so
i think it's a very important topic for
us to discuss
and uh maybe there's a bit of confusion
around this topic but i'm excited to
hear what you have to say on having the
faith of jesus you know as we're
in this time of earth history many
people are looking for answers and we
believe that the bible has the answer to
life's biggest questions and so if this
is your first time tuning in we want to
do a quick review then we're going to
dive right in so our first presentation
we looked at
man's problem god solution we talked
about humanism man trying to build this
this utopian society without god and we
see that we're all experiencing what
this utopian is literally falling apart
like you don't have to be a believer to
see that yo something's serious wrong on
planet earth and so we also saw that man
is trying to come up with its own
remedies and those remedies have failed
and so we also came to a point that
guess what god has the remedy and so
then we looked at the second
presentation god's remedy for the
world's problem is found in the church
but then we looked at the challenge of
the church because the church looks like
it has just as many problems as the
world if not more if not more right and
so we found that because the church has
problems because there's no unity and
then every man's doing that what's right
in his own eyes right so you have the
baptist and the buddhists and this and
that and every you know all these
different things and so not buddhist but
you have the baptist and you have the
all these different denominations but
jesus prayer was that they all might be
one that the world might believe that
you have sent me so then we looked at uh
jesus's love for man and we saw how
jesus loves the sinner we look at the
demoniac we looked at the woman caught
in adultery and he saw that god values
the human soul even though men may see
that life is cheap but god values and so
in our next session right now we're
going to look at jesus and the bible you
know many millions of people you know
the bible is the best-selling book year
after year after year but yet this book
has the most critics of any book ever
printed and so people are skeptical of
the bible people are questioning the
first uh 11 chapters is it real is it
historical is it allegorical is it a
myth who wrote the bible right
you know what about the gospel of thomas
what about the gospel of enoch what
about the why didn't they put this and
so what did jesus
think and believe and teach concerning
the bible
i think that that's really important for
us as believers and i think at
precedence that you kind of have to our
foundation that you have to understand
about the bible is you know the verse
that says that all scripture is used and
for doctrine and profitable right
so
i believe that the entire bible is
divinely inspired
and you know some people that say well i
believe some parts of the bible but i
don't believe other parts well then how
are you distinguishing between what is
inspired and what's not inspired that
wouldn't really be fair because then
it's you choosing like i believe this
part but i don't believe this part and
you know what i mean it's like it all
has to be from god
or it's you know there's no way to tell
the difference between who's who's who's
the one inspired one and not well as
christians we always have to go to who
jesus he's our example in all things so
jesus had a high regard for scripture
and quoted it often so i'm just going to
go rapid fire through some scriptures
and see how jesus used the bible so
let's look at some examples matthew 12
verse 3 says but he said unto them have
you not read what david now what
testament was that
psalms yeah so what testament did jesus
have
the only testament okay
so so many people say well i'm a new
testament christian well what what
testament christian was jesus so jesus
is quoting from david right he says have
you not read what david did when he was
in a hunger and they were with him so
notice it says or have you not read so
notice there's a pattern here in the law
how that on the sabbath days the priests
in the temples profane the sabbath of
blameless
chapter 19 verse 4 it says and he
answered and said unto them have ye not
read that he which made them at the
beginning made them male so what is
jesus's pattern right here people are
questioning him why are you doing this
why are you doing that does he say
because i'm jesus
what was his pattern of response
this is what it was said in the bible it
is written
right so i'm doing this because of thus
saith the lord funny how he packages it
he doesn't just say what's in the bible
but there's a little bit of rebuke
rebuking there like did you not read
this oh you don't know this like
remember yeah right have you ever heard
like they used to be able to like
literally pick a pen and they could push
it through and see exactly where it was
they knew the bible that way
i i've always kind of heard that as a
kid i don't know how true that is
so notice matthew 21 verse 16 and jesus
said unto them yay have ye not read out
of the mouth of babes and suckling thou
shall perfect praise matthew mark 12
verse 10
and have you not read this scripture so
notice he had a working knowledge of
scripture because guess what he's not
walking around with the scrolls
like have you not read no he's quoting
verbatim what the bible says so he had a
high regard for scripture do you guys
have people in your lives who can do
that easily just
i'm always impressed by that you know
people that just had can retain
incredible verses in their mind and then
bring them up at a spur of a moment
there's a preacher i know and he
literally preaches with the bible like
this and he literally just quotes
verbatim and so i was so amazed i went
up to him and i said how do you do that
and he said one verse at a time
and i was like it's true it's like but
he says i'm regimented
and actually recently i was i was going
door to door and i knocked on this guy's
door and we became friends and he
challenged me to memorize a verse every
single day that's awesome and he holds
me accountable once a week we go down
and we sit down and we quiz each other
and it ha it's actually enhanced my
relationship right so do we even need to
memorize it now that we have google yes
you know what happens what happens when
they turn off google you know you know
facebook went out the other day right
yeah chaos and and i saw a meme it had
little house in the prairie and it was
like one day without facebook
and so guess what you want the word in
here right right right notice what uh
mark 12 26 says have you not read in the
book of moses noted he quoted david
now he's quoting moses who wrote the
majority of the first uh of the first
part of the old testament it was moses
right so the question i have is why did
jesus quote scripture so much what was
he trying to teach his audience i think
in the beginning our downfall is god's
word said if you eat this fruit you'll
die we disregarded his words we did not
believe them we did not take them we did
not digest them as a human race and we
said whatever we're going to do our own
thing and and so i i think jesus
obviously coming as the as the
second adam you know and he's writing
what was wrong
he's showing us that we literally need
to take every word that proceeds out of
god's mouth
and seriously yeah and that's the system
of life i think he was also um
validating the promises of the old
testament he said he came not to change
the law but to fulfill it right so he
just keeps pointing back like okay you
need the first just kept asking them for
clues show us signs like well
there's the scripture right and here i
am do the comparison to your own
conclusion but it's interesting the
pharisees had a misconception or a
misinterpretation of the messiah
and so when the word became flesh and
dwelt among us they were like ah that's
that's not the word that i want and a
lot of times we see that in christianity
you can show them it thus saith the lord
but it's like i don't like that and so
now the bible bible's become a
smorgasbord of what i like versus what
you like and so jesus shows us like no
the word is the foundation of belief so
jesus wanted to call people's attention
to the word and the need to what
study have you not read don't you know
this and like candy says it's a it's a
christ-like rebuke
i i think you brought up a good point
though when we come to the word of god
with a prejudice
and i think that's often what the
pharisees and the sadducees did is they
had such a prejudice of what
they thought god was like
that when the truth was presented before
them the very lamb that takes away the
sins of the world when when they should
have recognized all the signs that
they've been doing for 400 plus years um
they should have said oh wait that guy's
that guy's like literally the lamb of
god you know and they didn't
i think it's it's because they came to
the table well prejudice in theological
terms it's called presuppositions
so all of us have presuppositions
through our experience through our
understanding through our upbringing and
we bring that as baggage right
philosophical baggage theological
baggage and so we see the bible through
our presuppositions but when we lay our
presuppositions down and let the word do
what it's supposed to do then it brings
us into the truth right thy word is a
what a lamp unto my feet and a light
unto my path so notice john 5 39 he says
what search the scriptures for in them
you think that you have eternal life so
who was he talking to
he was talking to the leaders right he
says you know the scriptures but do you
understand this experience that you're
supposed to have from the scriptures
right he says you think so what were
they reasoning with their own thoughts
their own philosophies their own and
that's what happens in the world today
you know we become wise in our own eyes
he says and they are which what
testified me so when you study the bible
we must come to the conclusion that
every word in scripture leads us where
to jesus that's right that's why when
jesus was resurrected and he's walking
with the two from the road to emmaus
right he had to be start from the
beginning right show them that line of
truth that literally constantly pointed
to him right right and they're blown
away and those are the followers those
are the disciples of jesus that were
walking along you know not one of the
twelve but they were they were people
that probably no doubt had heard a lot
of preachings that jesus did and he
still had to say look at all these
things that pointed to who i was right
and so
notice they testify of me so the purpose
of the word of god is they testify of
christ right so who was jesus speaking
to
in this context
he was actually talking to the pharisees
right notice what he says he says
ha and
for had ye believed what moses moses you
would have what believed me and for he
wrote of me so notice everything in the
old testament was pointing to
christ but they didn't believe moses
so when you reject what god sends to you
then guess what actually you're
preparing your way to reject christ so
how is that fair to say that they didn't
believe moses i mean that's their whole
world that's their lifestyle that's
their culture everything is built off of
these scriptures so for christ to come
in and say something like that
where do you think he's actually getting
it
so
they believed
what moses said right the words but then
the ideas and and the the foundation was
leading people to christ because think
about it moses wrote
genesis 3 15
right i will put enmity between the
woman and the serpent her seed right
moses wrote so many amazing scriptures
but then when those fulfillments came
they didn't see it why
because they had built up their own
system
of what they called truth you know they
had 600 and what 13 laws
and so so they built up their own
system and so anything that didn't fit
in that system they got rejected it's
like denominationalism right people
build up their system
of truth and then anything that comes
even if it's from the scripture
even if you can show them line up online
there's like well that doesn't fit with
what they say the popular thing that's
your truth
there are some church denominations and
i don't want to like just call them out
on the carpet and name them but they
will literally say
if if the difference of belief varies
from what the bible says we're going to
go with what our church is traditional
tradition and that's that's a scary
position to be in because you know then
then that's basically saying that this
is wrong but our tradition is more
correct and that's what the pharisees
did so this is what jesus is trying to
correct right
so notice believe moses you'll believe
me right so notice he wrote of me so go
back to creation we just talked about
this the fall the promise moses wrote
genesis 3 15 i would put enmity between
thee and the woman and between your seed
and her seed so notice moses laid the
foundation
right of the the bible uh uh religion
right and so it says he shall bruise thy
head and thou shall bruise his heel and
so notice what else moses wrote because
he said moses wrote of him in numbers
chapter 21 verse 8 and 9 it says and
lord said unto moses
make thee a fiery serpent and set it on
a pole remember what was going on in the
story they were in the wilderness they
were murmuring they're complaining and
god took away his hedge of protection
and guess what these fiery serpents came
in and they got
bit right and they're dying and so
notice what it says and it says it shall
come to pass that everyone that is
bitten
when he looks upon it shall what live
all they had to do was what yeah look
and live faith in action you know some
people say um you know oh man it's so
easy to sin like it is easy to sin right
don't you feel like that it's it's so
easy to not do something that's right
and sometimes it's so difficult to do
something that's that's that's good
right
but if it was that easy to get into sin
don't you think it would just be right
for god to make it that easy to get
together
and i think this illustration right here
is just looking little
yeah look can you imagine the people
that like literally got bit and were
like no i'm not gonna look no and i mean
you'd think like what a stubborn
don't we do that today
if it goes against
what i want what i believe i don't care
what it says i don't i'm not gonna do it
and we dig our heels in we'll throw it
out right yeah you got 10 verses that
tell you you know this this is the way
that it is and it's like that one verse
yeah that one verse we're not gonna look
at those ten we're gonna go with like
this more hard to understand one so all
they had to do was what look and live so
notice jesus application of these two
scriptures in john 3 14. he says and as
moses lifted up the serpent so now he's
making the old testament connection to
his life he said they testify of me in
the wilderness even so must what the son
of man be lifted up and whosoever
believes in him shall not perish but
have what eternal so we see that jesus
used moses's writing to explain his
ministry right so now we see these two
symbols we see the symbol and then we
come and we see the reality right so the
word became what flesh and dwelt among
us now i got a question for you just
kind of throwing this out there because
i've had people ask me this before why a
serpent why i mean that just seems like
that's a symbol of satan why would you
put that on the cross so who took the
penalty of sin that's right right i know
where you're going right so the serpent
was used in the garden to deceive right
he was like a you ever had a substitute
teacher
and the teacher gives you the lesson
plan and the substitute comes in and
guess what they throw out the lesson
plan and they do whatever they want and
then the teacher comes back like what
did you guys learn like well we did this
we did we watched the movie and the
teacher's like that's not what i told
him to do so satan comes into the garden
through the medium of a serpent and he
substitutes
his word for whose word god's word and
that's what's happened in the church
also so man is substituting their ideas
their philosophy for thus saith the lord
so this this body of believers that
revelation 14 talks about those who keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus they're going to be
faithful to the word of god and so
notice john 5 47 would you read that for
me but if you believe not his writings
what whose writings
moses moses right
he shall he how shall ye believe my
words so if you don't believe moses so
how can you be a new testament christian
only
right some people say well i'm a new
testament christian well guess what he
says if you don't believe moses's word
they say that's old covenant that's old
testament
i'm under the new covenant well jesus
says if you don't believe what moses
words and guess what you won't believe
my word
so notice so jesus is laying the
foundation my words are in harmony with
moses's words right so jesus
okay the pharisees they expected the
messiah to come as what the conquering
king he was going to come and destroy
the romans he was going to come and set
up jerusalem and make their name great
again right but then he actually came
how as a suffering servant and so they
read isaiah
but they only read the portions that fit
what they wanted
it is interesting that we use in
christianity a symbol of torture and
death to be our symbol of our savior
like you know you think of like the
symbol of superman
any symbol across the planet that has
ever tried to describe a hero
you don't use the instrument of torture
and death to be that symbol you know
what i mean and it's like christianity
it's it's it's like our hero was someone
that
was the top of the food chain and he
came down and laid down his life for us
that's not a typical thing that you see
and that's a symbol of how we're to live
our lives jesus said in matthew uh
thinks 20 28 he says i came not to serve
i mean not to be served but to serve and
to give my life a ransom right and so
notice jesus
suffered he died he resurrected now
notice you mentioned it earlier the road
to the maids now jesus could have come
to them in his glorified body
i am
master lord savior but notice what jesus
did he did not come to them that way why
do you think he didn't come to them in
his glorified self why did he come to
them as a stranger
i don't think we could have taken it
that's the first one
and it's glorified sin and righteousness
can't dwell on the same right same space
um
i oh god no i think it also gives us the
opportunity to get to know him
um
i think if he were to come in his
righteousness maybe we would have felt
like we were not good enough and maybe
some people would have ran and hid
from him well let's look at the word i i
think it's also when we come to that
understanding right what's the most
powerful thing is like when we see it
and and often in our line of work
sometimes when we're talking about like
movies and stuff it's like we're telling
people like you know there's these
things in the background and people will
will not believe what we're saying
they'll say you guys are crazy and
you know you're you're totally out of
your mind and then you know it's only a
matter of time you're going to sit in a
theater long enough and you're going to
see what we saw and and we've had people
who actually hated everything we've said
and years later will come back to us and
say i was sitting in this movie and i
saw exactly what you're talking about
and that for them to see it with their
own eyes was the most powerful thing and
i think that's what jesus wanted them to
do he wanted them to see with their own
eyes that this wasn't just like some
spirit showing up to him this was
planned from the beginning and this has
been played out already so and he wanted
their faith to be rooted in the word of
god not in this this miraculous because
we know in the last days says no marvel
that satan himself is transformed into
an angel of light and his ministers
are also so in these last days you're
going to have apparitions you're going
to have and so if you're not rooted in
ground in the word of god you can be
deceived so notice uh luke chapter 24
verse
25 brittany would you read that for us
please
oh fools and slow of heart to believe
all that the prophets have spoken so
what was their mistake they didn't
believe the words they were reading they
were slow
to believe
what all that the prophets had broken so
again he's referring back to moses right
isaiah ezekiel daniel right so notice
you didn't believe all they had bits and
pieces of it right but they didn't
understand the big picture it says ought
not christ to have suffered these things
and entered into his glory so notice
they didn't cut they didn't they weren't
looking for christ to suffer they were
looking for him to come as a conqueror
that's what they had been taught by
their pastors and their you know their
leaders so isaiah 53
it was in the old testament right isaiah
wrote it right he it says he would what
be despised and rejected a man of
sorrows acquainted with grief smitten of
god oppressed and afflicted as a lamb to
the slaughter but notice what did john
say when he saw jesus
so
the prophet pointed them back to who the
lamb to isaiah
but the illustration that they should
have been learning
from the sanctuary thousands of lambs
were
murdered
like sat there and said wow you know
like what is this symbol of right well
it seems like they skip the suffering
and jump to the reward because christ
will come as a king you know as a
conqueror yes coming in the future it
seems like they're focusing on that and
not the first coming and it's
interesting i think that that's the
generation we're living in
they want the reward but they don't want
the hard work and the suffering and the
self-denial
and right that they want the insta
whatever it is and they want the the
million views but they don't want to
make the thousand videos i don't want to
be a weird christian i just literally
want to believe in god just enough i
mean give me the least amount that i can
do to basically make it but i'm still
going to have fun over here right stand
out you know so notice isaiah 9. these
are prophecies in the old testament
wonderful counselor mighty god
everlasting father prince of peace now
didn't they have scripture memorized
these were not ignorant people right so
jesus is coming he's reminding them oh
yeah by the way all these things these
rituals and it's so important for us to
understand that sometimes our rituals
are separate from the relationship
right that's why it's believing in jesus
having faith in jesus and literally
having a relationship with him jesus god
is interested in relation he's a
relational being let us
make man in our image right and and love
must express itself to beings outside of
itself right and so what does jesus do
to reveal himself to them luke 24 verse
27 scotty would you read that for us and
the beginning at moses and all the
prophets
he expounded upon them all the
scriptures that that the things
concerning himself i would have loved to
be in that bible study amen
he went from genesis all the way to
malachi right and he explained oh yeah
by the way genesis 3 15 that was me oh
yeah by the way leviticus that was me by
the way deuteronomy literally walk them
through so here's kind of an interesting
um little
side note as well um when we read the
bible especially the old testament um we
need to be able to find jesus
in that context in fact your study will
just open up a whole new world right if
you say how does this passage here
pertain to to jesus because the whole
thing's pointing at him right right and
sometimes you know i don't know if
you've tried to read through the bible
in a year you know some people do that
and you know some people read through
the bible
right but have they grown in their
relationship with god have they
understood the character of god and so
it's possible to do the right things but
not understand the intent or the purpose
of what we're doing it's like using the
different uh uh social media platforms
you know if you go to facebook but
you're trying to use it like instagram
it's not gonna work if you go to youtube
you try to use it as linkedin you know
you have to understand the function and
the purpose so that you can get the best
out of it it's the same with the bible
the the purpose of the bible is to help
us grow
in christ it exposes right it's like a a
sword it oh it cuts it does surgery
shows us where sin is but it also draws
us closer to god as you say that
actually reminds me of a challenge that
i would challenge all our viewers to
actually find jesus in the old testament
so he's not labeled jesus because that
name came in the new testament but jesus
himself actually came to earth amen in
the old testament it's interesting
because we have mentioned
actually i was the one that mentioned it
on a few other shows like um talking
about you know jesus being in the old
testament and um when he was uh you know
interacting with the human race and
stuff like this and i remember some of
the comments that came out people were
like what jesus wasn't born in the old
testament in the new testament and it's
like wait a minute isn't that kind of a
basic christian understanding that he
was an incarnate meaning he existed
before right and so you know any time
that we see the angel of the lord like
when moses the burning bush right it
says the angel of the lord showed up and
he said take off your shoes for your
standing on holy ground burning bush and
he asks him who are you and he says i am
that i am that angel of the lord that
person that's before that was jesus
interacting before he was called jesus
or he came to birth so you know he is in
the old testament you just have to know
how to to dissect those and find well
actually that's that's cool can we
challenge the audience because that was
one example so if you can think of any
other examples or find jesus in the old
testament write that in the comment
section below
all right so the bible says the entrance
of thy words gives light right now jesus
he says and their eyes were what
and they what knew him so before they
knew about him
right but now
they know him personally right it says
and he vanished out of sight well wait
we know jesus and bam he's gone
so notice it says and they said one to
another did not are what hearts burn
within us while he what talked with us
by the way and what did he do
while he opened to us the scriptures
right so
as christians we need you know man does
not have the intellect i don't care how
many phds you have i don't know how many
doctors in theology you do not have the
intellect
to understand divinity that's right
spiritual things are spiritually
descended so how do you get a masters in
divinity yeah how do you master divinity
how do you do that there's only been one
build a relationship with god
the holy spirit amen so now we go to the
upper room right so now he goes to the
upper room now he could have done the
same thing he could have revealed
himself and somebody he does the exact
same thing uh luke
uh 24 44 it says and he said unto them
these are the words which i spake unto
you while i was at with you and all
things must be fulfilled which were
written in the law of moses the prophets
and the
psalms concerning what
so where is he referring them back to
the word of god so when he's talking
with the pharisees have you not read
when he's talking to the disciples in
the rosary maze have you not read don't
you know that this should have happened
when he talked to the disciples after
the resurrection he says guess what all
these things he gives them another bible
study so what are we learning about
jesus and the word of god
we have to be able to understand and and
know how to find jesus
right so why did jesus do this
why did he take the time and the effort
and energy think about these are like
two-hour bible studies right why did he
take such painstaking effort to root and
ground the early church in the word of
god because he knew it was coming he
knew how people would doubt and kind of
discredit the old testament
there would be so much confusion
you know but it's right there he's
saying no no no
they work together right right i think
he also knew that the devil's main tool
is to change the words of god
come on now i think that when the garden
of eden happened and the snake spoke to
eve i mean what the devil was
effectively doing was changing the words
of god god said this no that's not what
what's going to happen this is what's
going to happen and so even way back
then it began over a disbelief right the
word of god and we are no different we
are struggling with the same thing and
see what he did to jesus on the
temptation
jesus came it is written it is written
and what the devil say it is also
written
so the devil knows the scriptures right
he's he's been more bible studies than
come on than anyone else come on he had
he had god as his teacher
right yeah next to god next to god right
so what i can appreciate though is god's
consistency
there it is it's in the bible like you
can trust this you can go back to it
whereas a double there's always
something new it's always a different
package you know there's always some
kind of to see oh we gotta like sift
through this
so what does this teach us today see the
bible was central to all jesus lived and
taught jesus not only knew the bible but
he lived it out in what his daily life
and taught others to do the same so as
christians we're to live it out first in
our lives oh come on now if you can't
explain it to someone else do you really
know it no right but isn't that awesome
that god himself isn't asking us to do
anything that he himself was not willing
to do that's right and able to do right
so listen to his teachings now let's go
to his teachings right we've seen how
he's done this so luke 6 36 he says and
why call ye me lord lord and what do not
the things which i say oh so he's like
why are you calling me lord and master
when you don't even do what i'm asking
you to do or what i'm giving you an
example right
matthew 7 21 not everyone that says unto
me what lord lord shall enter into the
kingdom of heaven
but he that what do it the will of my
father which is in heaven he says many
will say unto me what lord lord have we
not
noticed notice how their works they're
presenting their works have we not
prophesied prophesied means preached i
mean i've done an evangelistic series i
went to africa i did this right he says
and in thy name cast out devils
i would say i had power i could cast out
devil he says and in thy name do what
many wonderful wonderful works so notice
how jesus responds and then i will
profess unto them
i what never knew that so how can a god
who knows everything and everyone he
counts all the hairs on our beards and
our heads right
but yet when it comes to the last he
says i never knew you that word no is
like adam knew his wife and cain and
abel were born it's an intimacy right
he's like yes you knew about me yes you
could you knew where i was born you knew
who my mother was but did you know me
intimately so the word of god leads us
to this intimate heart to heart
relationship with god he says depart
from me
ye that work what iniquity it's
interesting they say we've done all
these great things your name he says but
the works that you did were works of
iniquity
it's also kind of a testament that
knowledge isn't necessarily what saves
you because the pharisees had an
incredible amount of knowledge yeah i
mean you could have asked them some
pretty detailed stuff about the bible
they were schooled and you know they
knew what to answer and how to say it
but yet in their hearts they had this
murderous spirit you know they knew the
law like they prided themselves on how
well they kept the law yet inside they
were just like empty tombs even to the
point of
putting jesus away before the sabbath
right you know what i mean like trying
to wash their hands so that we can go
and celebrate the passover the very
thing that points to
the guy that you just killed that you
just you literally played out the
illustration right and then you're
worried about being unclean
the bible says the god of this world is
what blind blinded their minds right
remember we read that quote it says that
satan for a thousand years has been
experimenting on the mind so you can
even
see it believe it read it hear it
understand it but yet when the word
becomes flesh and you're confronted with
that
then do i really believe i know you've
heard the illustration of the person who
walked across the niagara falls with the
with the the wheelbarrow and everybody
well there's a guy he's a tight
walker he walks across and everybody's
like he's like do you believe i can do
it like yes i believe
you think i'd do a wheelbarrow yes i
believe it says who's willing to get in
the wheelbarrow they were like
so they believed he could do it he did
it they could believe they could do it
with the with the wheelbarrow he did it
they believe then they said do you
believe i can do it with somebody in the
world they believe but then what when he
said who's going to volunteer see belief
and action faith without works is what
dead so jesus takes the word of god
seriously and guess what so should we so
why should we take it see words
thoughts
words are thoughts made audible right so
thoughts reveal the character of the man
so when god's word actually what reveals
his character
so when god speaks right something
happens right it reveals his thoughts
his divine character the bible is god
revealing his thoughts so what does the
bible say about his love for you what's
god's what does the bible say about god
he is love he is love okay what else
does the bible say about god
i'm putting you on the spot
uh he is the creator our savior he has
our best interests at heart
he's selfless right sacrificial um he's
patient right and he's sovereign
so guess what many people are fearful
in this pandemic time
many but guess what psalm 91 says what
that the pestilence shall not come nigh
thee
it says a thousand may fall at your
right hand in ten thousand and yet you
have believers who are literally the
bible says perfect love cast out fear
because fear has torment i know people
who will not leave their house who are
bible believing christian
they will not leave their house and i
say
who is more powerful now obviously we're
not going to be presumptuous right but
who is more powerful god
or the enemy right because sickness does
not come from god right so we know that
in the last days pestilences are going
to come all this stuff is telling us
jesus is coming jesus is coming and i
think it's psalm there's somewhere in
the bible see i need to get that down
but it says the curse doesn't come
without a card come on
so you have these believers getting sick
believers like things are happening and
instead of
delving in and trying to figure out why
because it takes more than just them yes
yes they lock themselves in their homes
and they're so much fair so question has
god given us a health message absolutely
uh-oh now he's stepping on toes
i think he gave us a health message
[Music]
and you see this coming in the end it
should not be fearful it should be like
oh wow my faith is being reaffirmed
in the bible that's happening now in our
world and god gave us
the information ahead of he said i tell
you those things before they happen so
that when they do happen what you might
believe so the unbelievers
are fearful
right because that's what happened with
the demons right yeah it says they
feared and trembled i like how god when
he's asked you know who are you who do i
who do i go and tell this pharaoh this
person of the earth right and he says i
am right i mean he's just like like i am
you fill that blank in with anything
i'm your sustainer you're king you're
sovereign you're you know your friends
you're all mighty your friends
love your everything i say everything to
you so question who does god reveal his
thoughts to then
does he reveal his thoughts to everyone
and anyone no
i think it's to anyone who wants to know
him
anyone who wants to know him i i'm
automatically led to the verse that says
um if you seek me with all your heart
you will find me okay
so for what purpose does god reveal his
thoughts that's what i was thinking i
think he's very
precise that's the movie tells what
because he says you know no man knows
when i'm coming that's something that he
has kept from revealing to us but
everything that is essential for our
salvation all right whom shall we teach
knowledge whom shall he teach knowledge
of whom shall he make to understand
doctrine so the answer is found in the
next verse them that are weaned from the
milk
and drawn from the breast so how does he
teach us so basically the breast and the
milk is babies yes so on a very
practical level that's everybody that's
everybody right so so how does he teach
us the bible says from precept must be
upon precept precept upon precept so how
the god does not reveal everything at
once so notice it's little by little by
little he told disciples i have so much
i want to tell you but you can't what
handle it that's a good
way for us as christians to deal with
other people who might not be where
we're at sometimes we want to dump the
whole
you know and they're like oh
you know no little by little notice what
it says line upon line precept upon line
upon line little here little there
little so he gradually sows us as much
as what we can grasp apply
in our daily life isn't god merciful
right
notice mark it says for the earth
bringeth forth fruit of herself
first the one
blade then the air the ear after that
the full ear so this is how god teaches
right he began at genesis and he gave
them little by little by little all the
way to malachi i i just want to say a
pause here real quick just on um
critical
you know being critical of people where
they are and walking in their life i
mean think about that we're all growing
in christ right and some of us are at a
different spot and
and you know i just i've seen over the
years people going well you just don't
understand this rather than coming with
a very like you know gentle loving
spirit and understanding give people the
space they're all different at different
levels
and we're all learning and so you know
if you have something to share share it
but share it in love don't share it in a
critical spirit so in this picture the
man is doing what
castings
he's so one man plants
another man
waters right but who gets the increase
god gives the increase right so little
by little this is the the method that
god uses right so it is written was
jesus's authority so as christians right
we're talking about the faith of jesus
as christians what should be our
authority what my pastor says
what my bishop said what the church says
what my mama did
what my grandmama did is that how no of
thus saith the lord so let us go to the
desert and see matthew 4 the tempter
said if thou what
again what does the what does the devil
always do yeah he's he's he's making you
question
because if you back up in the story what
happened just before jesus went into the
desert this is my
beloved son he gets baptized he hears
the voice of god right so at this point
right here he would have to say either
what i heard is not god wow
but he knew right he was the son of god
why because he had a relationship he
trusted the word of god right no angel
would doubt so notice if
was the the thing that gave him away
right you shall not surely die
because god does know so there's always
this insinuation that god is withholding
god is not his word can't be trusted
right he says turn these stones into
bread so we know that satan hates the
word of god he hates the son of god and
he hates the government of god so satan
always questions the word of god
the baptism we just talked about it
right so this is who my beloved so first
he claims jesus as his son
so if we accept christ guess what you're
his daughter
when you accept him in baptism you
become his son you become his child he
says i claim you then he says in whom i
am well pleased
right so he says guess what i'm pleased
with you you you you you bring joy to me
right now when your child messes up
do you be like oh i don't i you don't
please me anymore
when you're trying to walk no
even in their mistakes
even when they don't do things right
guess what you at least they made the
effort
right so this is a picture of god and so
in the garden there was insinuation
right has god said so satan always
questions the word so if you're involved
in any community
that questions any part of the word of
god guess what red flag number one yeah
good point right and so what was jesus's
response then we know it was written
man shall not live now where was he
quoting from man shall not deuteronomy
chapter eight he's literally quoting
verbatim so again jesus had a command of
the word of god second testimony if i
mean second test temptation if thou be
the son of god what cast myself down
cast yourself down right if so there's
that insinuation for now satan what does
he do oh you want to quote scripture
i got scripture quoted too he says
he will give his angels charge over thee
and in his hands thou shall bear thee up
now where is he quoting from
do you know
psalm 91
but he's quoting the last half
he doesn't quote the part where you put
your trust in god you put no he's
quoting so he's literally misquoting out
of context and so oftentimes people
believe things but they believe them
what out of context and notice how he's
puffing him up with a little bit of
pride come on now you know what i mean
he's like you know yeah yeah yeah you
know if you if you really are the son of
god you know you've got you got all this
that you're wrong right and he promises
so he he claims god's promise but it's
it's he he rejects god's power
right so this is presumption right i
also love how um
how jesus you can really tell where his
identity comes from because he doesn't
feel the need to prove himself right
like anyone else would have been like oh
i can make this right
now you don't believe me
so he had assurance
of his identity within the father he
heard the voice right and a lot of
christians lack assurance and he
believed the words that he heard
come on now so notice it is written his
response thou shall not what tempt the
lord thy god so now the third temptation
all these things will i what
give thee now question was it his to
give no no right
so so he presumptuously presumes that he
has the power and the authority to get
guess what he
actually stole
from adam through deception and he is a
defunct
pirate he's a pirate right you're gonna
say something no you you
because i thought yeah so this is to
give because adam transferred ownership
onto the devil but then you clearly
right right go ahead so if thou will
what what does he really want
fall down and worship worship
so notice the devil wants our worship so
whether he gets it through sports
whether he gets it through relationships
movies music fashion it does even in the
church if you're worshiping falsely
who inhabits that false worship
there's also a little window into here
that a lot of christians i think um they
think of look at the greater good that
i'll do if i go against what the bible
says right and you know if you think
like this little tiny action here
i know the bible says not to do that but
look at all the people i'm gonna save
how many times does do we rationalize
what we're doing for the greater do the
ends justify the means right so for
jesus the answer is no right so notice
jesus then jesus says unto him get thee
hence satan
for it is written thou shalt worship the
lord thy god and him only shalt thou
serve
i have a question about the about the
three
he tempts jesus three times right and
after that it's literally like nope
you've tried
go away
how many times was peter really kind of
tempted three times you know what i mean
right so if you think about if the devil
is nipping at your heels and you resist
that resist that resist that he can't
stand there and keep doing that all the
time he's gotta he's gotta walk away
jesus said hey get away that's right and
what did he say to peter get thee behind
me
satan so he understood it wasn't peter
we wrestle not what against flesh and
blood right right so so notice jesus
here gives us an example of how to
overcome when we are tempted jesus used
the word as a weapon right the weapons
of our warfare are not what carnal but
they're mighty through god to the
pulling down of strongholds so when
jesus was challenged or questioned he
used scripture to answer so notice luke
it says and behold a certain lawyer
stood up and tempted him saying master
what shall i do to inherit eternal life
he said unto him
what is written in the law i love how
jesus
didn't just did he know the answer to
him he said you tell me
he wanted to know what is your
understanding of the word sometimes and
i'm guilty of this a lot you know people
ask me questions and i know the answer
i'm just like
and i learned i had someone ask me a
really serious question and it floored
me recently and i remember what jesus
did and i said well how do you read in
the bible
and he told me well the bible says this
but tradition says this and i said well
which one are you going to follow
tradition of the word and he was like
but my mom and my dad i said are you
going to follow your mother your father
you're going to follow jesus
and you know what he made the decision
and he's like this is going to be hard i
say he said what straight and narrow
is the way and few be that find it you
know the way that you approach that
though is how jesus would do it as well
because i think leading that person to
to understand that himself rather than
you just giving him the answer right he
came to that conclusion on his own and i
think that that was a a powerful
conviction in his world and now the word
is the foundation not what london said
or scotty said or no the word right so
how read is thou so and he answered and
said thou shalt what love the lord your
god with all your heart with all your
soul with all your strength now he's
quoting here
so notice jesus is quoting but guess
what back then
they had scripture memorized so he could
quote this to this young man and the
young man had a a a a bible rolodex of
scriptures right and so he was so well
versed he was like oh that's leviticus
right so nowadays it's really hard
because guess what instead of a rolodex
of scriptures they gotta roll decks of
songs and movies and chats and and so we
have become biblically illiterate
right i've even heard people quote they
thought they were quoting a book but
they were actually quoting jesus
right so we are not as familiar with the
word of god and so now satan can come in
and he can twist and change this comma
or this dotted and we we file for it
hook line and seeker and so uh he said
do this and live so question
why such a big emphasis on the scripture
and its authority
i i actually have a good verse i was
looking up while you were you were
talking there second thessalonians 2 9.
i don't know if you're going to bring
that up in this go ahead how do i steal
your thing no no no thunder
we know that the end is going to come
with a crazy deception that i mean i
think that that's why this verse we've
said it a million times on on this show
and i feel very strongly about this
because it goes along with what you're
saying right here why is scripture so
much of
an importance for us in these last days
because we know satan's going to use
a a delusion in the end that's going to
take us our focus away from the
scripture
2 thessalonians 2 9 even him whose
coming is after the working of satan
with all power and signs and lying
wonders and all deceivableness so what's
coming in the end is going to be this
crazy deception and all unrighteousness
in them that uh uh with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness and
them that perish because they receive
not a love of the truth and that they so
might be saved and for this cause god
shall send them a strong delusion that
they should believe a lie and that they
all might be damned who believed not the
truth but had pleasure in
unrighteousness okay so now we have to
answer the question what is truth
the word of god
okay give me a scripture
sanctify them by thy truth thy word is
truth right so now is the truth someone
or something
jesus says i am the what way
so if we only know the the the ink on
the paper
right we can prove the truth
but jesus is not the truth right we can
still be deceived because guess what did
the pharisees know the word of god yes
right but did they know
relationally yeah god
no right so notice in the beginning was
the word the word was god that's the
verse i had and what
the word
was god right and the word was what made
flesh
and dwelt among us and guess what we be
notice the experience
so in these last days the world is not
going to respond to the word
[Music]
it's saturated come on
they're going to respond to the word
becoming flesh
and wow jesus really brought that to
life because obviously the old testament
wasn't enough yes he needed to show up
visual
expression yes it says and and it says
that which we have touched that which we
have heard that's what we have seen with
our own that is what we declare unto you
it's experiential
not informational right and so we live
in an information age and so people are
inundated with media with information
but guess what when they see it when
they see a christ-like character when
they see forgiveness when they see
kindness and and and gentleness and
self-control right when they see this
they're like wow that's powerful
and so the church is to rise up and the
word has to become flesh again
and so jesus is god's word god's
thoughts god's grace god's love made
visible
so in the last days which i believe
we're living in the world is not going
to respond to the word of god until the
word is made visible again see jesus
reveals the character of god the father
lessons what are some lessons that we
can learn as we end you see the
pharisees were always arguing with him
over the word
they could never find anything wrong
with his life he said which of you
convicts me of sin
like don't you wish you could say that
scotty
which of you
can find any fault with me right
remember daniel yeah they went after
daniel 120 they're looking they're
looking they're like they said man we
can't find anything wrong with his
business with his family the only thing
we can find wrong with his wife
his worship
we have worship we have to make a law
against them and make that and that's
where we're headed today they tried to
cancel daniel
they tried
jesus right and so notice they were
always coming after him over they were
nitpicking because they had nothing on
his character and that's this remnant
church in the last days people are going
to come not because they're they're
they're they're they're they're not
they're not uh believing in the right
things they're gonna be because we're
gonna be thriving notice i said we
right we're gonna be thriving we're
going to be successful not because of
anything that we've done because we have
allowed god's character to be reflected
i have a quick question yes so
just in light of this what does it mean
when we are to be perfect in christ what
is that is he an image of that
yes so question how was christ perfect
where did he derive
his power from god i do nothing outside
of the father right that's right
so so i've heard it explained this way
that jesus was born
and his temptation was not our
temptation
candy can you turn stones into bread
so that's not really tempting to you
right so the devil will never tempt us
with something we cannot do right so
jesus's temptation was to use divinity
right for himself
so if he would have turned the stones
into bread which he could do
he had to reframe because guess what if
he turned those stones into bread none
of us could do that and so people could
say look that's jesus
he's god right and so jesus had come off
the cross if you be the son of god could
he have come down yeah absolutely right
so his temptation
was the reverse of what our temptation
is right
our temptation is not to
indulge in sin
his which is selfishness his temptation
was not to use his power
for himself it says he humbled himself
even to the death of the cross even
though he was equal god because the
devil would have just literally held up
a mirror and been like see you're not
fair right you just played unfair right
right
and if you played unfair then god's
unfair and you know the whole thing
would have crumbled from there so
okay so perfection is not
never making a mistake no it's just
relying on god it's it's always okay
first the blade
then the right so it's the process of
growth
we will always grow because god is
perfect we'll never be what god is but
we're to grow
in grace
right so
21 years i've been a christian does that
mean i'm perfect
absolutely ask my wife ask my kids
right but guess what i'm way different
than i was when i first became a
christian
five years in i was weighed so this
growth process and so i'm perfect where
i'm at today but guess what will today's
perfection be tomorrow's mm-hmm
no so every day i'm growing in grace
does that answer your question yes
your temptation
morph and change what you were tempted
with years ago may not be what your
temptation is today
so as you kind of move through that
relationship with god the devil kind of
changes his tactics
trying to get you at a different spot
you know
which i guess is a compliment huh yeah
so let's finish up so uh we're gonna go
to john
and notice it says then the jews enter
saying for a good work we stone thee not
but for blasphemy
and because thou being a man what
maketh thyself god so what is blasphemy
when a man
makes himself god right and what was
what was it he said you shall be what
like god right so jesus answered and
said
is it not written in
your life
that's great i said ye are gods
now some people are like what in the
world what are you saying that we're all
god right so that word god means judges
that god is the judge right and so it
says if he called them gods or judges
unto whom the word of god came and the
scripture cannot be broken what did he
say the scripture cannot be broken so i
don't care what people say i don't care
what man does god's word is sovereign it
stands the test of time that's why 2 000
years later
it's still the best-selling book
on the planet right and so
notice if he called them gods or
magistrates judge he says the scriptures
what cannot be broken so if you are a
believer if you are interested in
becoming a believer if you're struggling
with being a believer guess what god's
word is the foundation of our faith and
so as we look at the life of jesus where
did he divide get his faith from
from the word of god right thy word is
what a lamp unto my feet and a light
unto my path so i love this picture to
end up what do you guys see here
a prophet passing on
a squirrel to a modern man right so
jesus has passed down the scroll the
truth from generation to generation to
generation and guess what has there been
opposition against the truth
is there opposition today
but the bible says in daniel chapter 2
verse 44 that god is going to come and
he's going to set up an everlasting
kingdom right and what we're seeing
happening in the world today is leading
to the culmination of scripture
and so we can have absolute confidence
that god's word will not go void it will
accomplish that which he send it to amen
powerful man
thank you so much for for enlightening
us i mean the word of god is such a an
amazing gift that god gave us that we
can actually sit and and
hear literally as if it was god audibly
speaking to us today and what was
relevant for those people back then
great picture to end on is relevant for
us today i think if you spend any time
with any culture over any part of the
planet's history you would see that
today we literally struggle with the
same things that they did and that that
struggle god has given us guidance how
to manage that how to deal with that how
to overcome that and so if it is your
desire to really learn and and and
digest and be able to understand the
word of god try them out test it see if
it's true and ask god
show me what you are saying right here
in this passage and when you do that i
believe that god will impress upon your
mind what he wants you to know so thank
you guys for tuning in to led live once
again this is london lee and uh he's
been doing a great series on the faith
of jesus
stay tuned we're gonna have some more
[Music]
[Applause]
you